I decided to go directly to the Arab
capitals and to make the historic
Abraham Accords uh and essentially uh
reversing the equation not a peace
process that goes inside out
but outside in and we went directly to
the uh the uh these countries and forged
these uh these breakthrough Peace
Accords with the United Arab Emirates
with Bahrain with Morocco and with Sudan
and we're now trying to expand that in a
Quantum Leap
with Saudi Arabia what does it take to
do that with Saudi Arabia with the Saudi
Crown Prince Mohamed besama you know I'm
a student of history and I
read a lot of history and I read that uh
you know in the Versailles discussions
after World War one uh President Woodrow
Wilson said I believe in open covenants
openly arrived at I have my correction I
believed in open Covenant secretly
arrived at so there's we're not going to
advance a Saudi Israeli Peace by having
it publicly discussed and in any case
it's a decision of the uh of the Saudis
if they want to do it but there's
obviously a mutual interest so here's my
view
if we try to wait for the two percent in
order to get to the 98 we're going to
fail and we have failed if we go to the
98 we have a much greater chance of
persuading the two percent you know why
because the two percent the Palestinian
uh hope to Vanquish the state of Israel
and not make peace with it is based
among other things on the pro on the
assumption that eventually the 98 the
rest of the Arab world will kick in and
destroy the Jewish State help them to
dissolve or destroy the Jewish State
when that hope is
um uh taken away then you begin to have
a turn to the realistic Solutions of
coexistence by the way they'll require
compromise on the Israeli side too and
then you know
I'm perfectly cognizant of that and
willing to do that but I think a
realistic compromise will be struck much
more readily when the
conflict between Israel and the Arab
states the Arab world is effectively
solved and I think we're on that path it
was a conceptual change just like you
know I've been involved in a few I told
you the conceptual battle is always the
most difficult one and you know I had to
fight this battle
to convert a semi-social estate into a
free market Capital estate and I have to
say that most people today recognize the
power of competition and the benefits of
free markets so we also had to fight
this battle that said you have to go
through the you know the the the
Palestinian uh uh straight
s-t-r-a-i-t to get to the other places
there's no way to avoid this you know
you have to go through this this uh
impassable pass and I think that now
people are recognizing that will go
around it and probably Circle back and
that I think actually gives hope not
only to have an arab-israeli piece but
circling back in israeli-palestinian
peace and obviously this is not
something that you find in the you know
in the sound bites and so on uh but but
in the popular discussion of the press
but that idea is permeating and I think
it's the right idea because I think it's
the only one that will work so expanding
the circle piece just to linger on that
requires what secretly talking
man to man human to Human
uh to leaders of other nations
theoretically you're right theoretically
okay